[Music]
welcome aboard TV lovers this is ship
worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating the most swim worthy couples
on TV now as always I'm your host slash
captain leonid Galera and i am so
excited because today we are deep diving
into the pure and passionate
relationship between the bold types Kat
and Adina aka Kadena you are very
relentless have no idea in addition to
navigating this ships best naughty or
nice moments I'm splashing you with an
exclusive never-before-seen interview
with Asia Dee and Nicole whoosh eerie
talking all about how much they love
their ship it feels nice in your mouth
Kadena yeah but first let's take a look
back at how this wonderfully unexpected
relationship first sailed on to our
screens in Anchors Away although Kadena
has evolved into one of the best LGBTQ
couples on TV it wasn't always smooth
sailing for these two fierce females
when Kat first approached Adina with the
idea of doing a feature with scarlet she
was swiftly shut down my Twitter bio
literally reads proud with some lesbians
I would come out to the whole world if
it was the right place but scarlet and I
are not a good match but Kats
persistence and a unique form of
contraband bribery caused Adina to say
yes to a working relationship and the
two women begin to develop an open and
honest friendship you honestly I
actually really get the whole girl thing
I do but you know for me I could just
never get past this well for me it's
never just been about this it's more
about this despite the fact that Kat
identified as a quote out-and-proud
hetero it was clear from the text
message that something special was
brewing between these two as they spent
more and more time together the two
women developed a strong connection and
during a quiet night out Kat jumped to a
Dina's defense when an ignorant man
uttered an unprovoked racial slur
nice to my friend right now okay don't
touch me you dirty little towel head
after that experience cat had an
epiphany about her feelings for Adina
you're the only person I've ever met who
you know completely throws me off my
game and then the two ladies shared
their first kiss and it was everything
we could have hoped for and more
[Music]
now I don't know about you but after
that build-up I felt exactly like Jane
and Sutton in the fashion closet I
kissed a girl and you liked it and you
liked it
now that we've recapped how this ship
first came afloat let's take a look at
some of cadena sweetest and steamiest
moments in naughty or nice
one of my favorite nice moments between
these two cuties was back in episode 4
when they were watching the violinist
Adina's small action of taking Kats
phone had a big impact what I'm
confiscating all right point taken watch
listen be in the movie and of course we
can't talk about adorable moments
without highlighting that swoon worthy
night in the airport you know I'm
thinking about starting a new photo
series oh really yes the working title
is the woman inside the pillow fort I
love how much Adina and Kat opened up to
each other that night and it led to one
of the couple's best naughty scenes with
that sultry first-class lounge makeout
sesh
[Music]
the cuteness between cadena only grew
stronger in the season 2 premiere when
the two ladies shared a sweet yet very
candid conversation about their bedroom
rendevouz my god I've never talked about
oral sex so much in my entire life and
the bold type then gifted viewers was a
wildly passionate and refreshingly
honest
sexy between two women but the nicest
scene we've had between captain Adina so
far has got to be the exchange of those
three little words I love you Kat I love
you too okay I think the only people who
love Kadena more than the fans are the
actresses who play them now take a look
at what Asia Dee and Nicole boo Sheree
had to tell me about why these two women
are so wonderful together I think that
the members you just meet people that
you we were talking about this there's
just a magnet you're two magnets to each
other and like it's unavoidable and
there's nothing really you can do about
it and I think that that's I think we
felt it even working together that like
these two people are just very drawn
together and Adina is obviously the more
experienced a little older mature and
Kat is coming in to herself as a woman
as a bisexual woman I don't I love that
we don't feel like we need to put it
like labels on it either and it's not
often that you get to see a woman in her
20s figuring out her sexuality it kind
of up to now seems like it was reserved
for like teenagers and people that you
thought you know would be figuring out
their sexuality but it's a lifelong
thing you know your sexuality of evolves
as long as you're alive and it's really
cool and I love that she just discovers
it how I would discover how anyone would
discover it there's no shame there's no
shame in it there's no like angst in it
it's just like oh she's cute that's it I
also love the fact that in the season
two premiere we got a Streamy scene
between these ladies what does it mean
for you to have a network that's just
like yes go for it show something that
you typically don't get to see on a teen
centric show mom's been so supportive of
every way that the show like pushes the
envelope it's really cool to be
playing such an amazing character and on
a show and a network that champion is
like doing some stuff that has not been
done before on TV I'm traditional
stories new stories that we haven't seen
before told in this particular way we
haven't seen two women I mean very you
very rarely see I'm kind of Lingus
period on screen especially TV calling
we talk about it so much in the episode
we may as well be talking about it now
to you so yeah it's cool well to me it's
always just it's been a love story it's
like a romantic comedy too you know and
I can definitely relate to that you know
when you've never been in a relationship
before it's very exciting and you just
want to scream it to the heavens and you
want to be with that person forever
because you just don't really know what
you're getting yourself into yet and
that was something I was really happy to
see that the writers kind of like tapped
into that part of my brain I don't know
how they did it I love those two ladies
and overall I love cadena because this
is a couple that is made up of too
fierce and unafraid females who fell in
love with each other spirits you know
Adina is representing the Muslim faith
with Grace and strength while Kats
journey as a bisexual woman has been
inspiring together they've showed the
bold types audience that love is not
limited by a person's gender and that
does it for this first cadena episode of
ship worthy but have no fear as I
continue to interview Asia and Nicole
I'll be back with future episodes
talking all about where this couple will
be sailing to next but for now please
give this video a like and then hit the
comments to tell me why you think Kat
and Adina are totally ship worthy oh and
let me know your top naughty or nice
scenes and be sure to nominate which
other couples you think I should feature
on future episodes of ship worthy thanks
for watching and bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]